hey this Pete peppers here and I'm gonna
add some tips to a level 60 video that I
just made the commentary video so this
is a pretty tough level because of the
setup of the board so you can see I
picked that one up here because I wanted
to stun them I wanted to stun the first
because everything I do down here is
just gonna spread her green stuff out so
sassy when I go ahead and take the the
third stun so now you can see the board
sparkling so that I can hopefully
leverage some of the things that I did
to get one of those little explosions to
cover part of it but I have to spread my
jam at the same time so the trick to
this level because our Jam is all
separated at the bottom is to use this
dispenser in the middle so I don't
really have anywhere I could do it so I
had to spread it green now that looks
pretty bad and and it can be but the
thing is is that since we don't have
that much we have to cover the whole
board anyways so the specials can
actually help us out down the road to
cover the entire board so even though
we're starting out way behind if we plan
out things so that we get where we want
to go then we can we can just cover the
whole board so now my red was opened up
down here so let's go ahead and spread
that out and I'm looking for a way to
spread this red in the middle if I can
so you can see that it's
just gonna drop drop stripes for us so
we can stun her first and now we can we
can match those together and that'll
give us some that will spread us in the
middle you can also I didn't really
wanna lose that color bomb like that
bright green but can't always figure out
where everything's gonna go but it we
would like to see that we have the whole
bottom open and so when whenever our
pieces fall between the from below the
dispenser we'll be able to hopefully get
some stripes and some other specials
together so that we can cover the whole
board at this point not everything's
opened up and that's important so we're
gonna look to try to set up like I did
right here a bomb and then we're gonna
try to combo the bomb with something so
that the board will get you know pretty
much cover with our color and one go
yet another bomb up top that fell so
that's a good deal and now we match with
the striped we should be able to cover
up and sass the rest of the squares
I went ahead and made the mass at the
bottom one just because I knew I'd lose
the other bottom from the process but
now I think we can just go ahead and
match the bottom plus the Striped since
you wear that leave us off if nothing
else he's kind of connected to where the
Queen doesn't really have any sweet
anything to work with and we still have
five moves left so let's she had a
pretty good spur here but let's look for
just look for a couple more combos and
we should be able to finish it off all
right so now we have a bomb in the fish
and hopefully I think there should be
enough so the tips on this I you know in
the beginning I didn't really want to
spread that much of the Queens but you
know don't worry about it if you do
remember the goal is you get rid of
those blockers at the bottom so that you
can have some room and then whenever you
spread the you know the the red from the
dispenser on the bottom half just look
for bombs and combos so that you can
really like concentrate on covering the
whole board instead of just sort of
chipping away at it back and forth with
her because this is one of those levels
you have to get 78 78 squares which is
the entire board so if you just kind of
go back and forth with her in the
beginning and don't focus on the endgame
which is to cover the entire thing
you're probably going to run out of
moves before you can finish it so I hope
this helps I know it's a tough level it
took me a few tries to get through it
again in the second time so that's what
I've learned and I hope it'll help
please like the video and subscribe to
my channel so you can find more videos
with tips in the future thanks